anwar hussein began an extraordinary
life behind the lens
photographing rock stars and film stars
but the ultimate celebrity family
became his life's work for more than
half a century
royal tours took him to nauru nepal new
zealand
and everywhere in between capturing the
queen
and at her side or in the background but
always there
was the duke of edinburgh it's an
extraordinary life that he lived
and you were living it right alongside
him
yeah all the color around the world as
one of the royal family's favored
photographers anwar was given license to
capture them in more private moments
he didn't like other photographers he
he'd rather tell him
he never told me he always used to say
oh you're still at it
yeah he had a wicked sense of humor he's
credited with helping transform their
image from stiff
and stuffy to relaxed and relatable
the queen liked this picture of the
family in montreal in 1976
so much she made it an official
christmas card they were there to watch
princess anne compete at the olympics it
wasn't
unusual normally if a royal family
goes away they leave somebody ahead
behind
and this time they all went
but i told them that i wanted this the
first time history being men
you've never been out of the country and
we've got to have this picture and
we must recall the stretch of what do
you have together
he was also on hand to witness the
vulnerable moments of the queen and her
husband
in morocco they were in the desert and
they had to sit down on the floor and
have
a lime to roast their lives eat with
their hands
and you can see the picture the duke is
very very concerned
and looking at the queen for the silver
jubilee tour in 1977
anwar travelled 80 000 kilometers
alongside the royal couple
duke and queen liked that cultural
dancing and
celebration of the ways of living and
everything like that
and also he's quite fascinated about
seeing men in grass
skirts and things like that you know
i don't know whether he was pulling the
leg or whether they understood his sense
of humor
he was known as being quite direct oh
yeah he was terribly direct
absolutely and
especially with local people he used to
you know save all sorts of things like
that
and go to everything prince philip was
most relaxed
spending time on the water at the
balmoral estate or carriage driving
which replaced polo as his sport of
choice
i think he quite like the uh
where we didn't have to wear uniform
they quite like
being overseas outside their own friends
and family
there's nobody who has spent more time
with the royals
up close and personal martha kellner sky
news
chippenham